moto pour moi a yo tout en s'excusant
serait aujourd'hui sur battlefield 3 pc
ou mac et qui vient tous riches précise
a entendu alors écoutez j'ai jamais fait
de vidéo sur 29 et 3 sur ma chaîne ou
alors ça date quand même pas mal même
vraiment vraiment pas mal en tout cas
c'était insu si je l'aï aimé ça devait
pas être trop mac enregistrés ou break
du coup la dapa on n'a pas les arbres
qui ne bloque c'est incroyable ça j'ai
endossé le jeu où tu te fais bloqué par
un oiseau ou tu sais tu es sur une moto
non c'est l'oiseau qui te défonces
tendance boeing est alors attendez on va
s'arrêter direct on va faire un truc de
ouf remettre d'ici quatre ans avec
l'autorité
alors ça va être un truc de malade ce
qui va se passer tant si la moto n'est
fait mais c'est quoi cette moto elle
vient de 6 c'est la moto a oui voyons
quoi voilà robert marquié alors lui
l'idéal en fait je vous montre une
petite technique que je fais souvent bon
ça peut être considéré comme une
technique d'enculés bat hervé est mais
mais mais mais mais on va dire que non
parce que vous allez tout de suite
comprendre pourquoi alors oui c'est
d'atomiser quelques véhicules grâce à ça
le métis montre sur un circuit
ou alors sinon en attendant de trouver
le véhicule a atomisé
je voulais vous parler du nguen de ce
mât pas qui est le dernier de son nom
ngage fin du jeu pour le coup je joue
pas énormément à bata depuis trois jeux
là vous je me fais un truc astier la
[ __ ] joue pas énormément au on les
prend en chasse je paie normalement non
et les doutes la grèce lui il est trop
bien élevé monte sur la moto de respect
chez mes mecs regard des bons à la terre
et la vue ou touriste et jamy case gg à
la technique de trou du cul de la mort
enfin bref je disais ouais donc end game
j ai pas bon je suis pas un très très
grand joueur de bf3 même s'il ya
quelques temps j'ai joué quand même
vraiment beaucoup mais je dois avoir
quoi peut-être senteurs de jeu ce qui
n'est pas énorme pour un jeu qui est
sorti quand même depuis un an wingren
même plus je sais pas je sais même plus
quand il est sorti au final elle monte
pour fait la même erreur au final je moi
à chaque fois j'arrive sur un nouveau
mât pâques en fête bat là par exemple il
ya celui d'avant j'étais supporter chez
warner est cool moi je me souviens même
plus de l'ordre mapaq succès que le
premier s'était bac tout cas quelqu'un
mais du coup est là je découvre toutes
les maps packs d'un coup et pour moi
suivre est quand même assez drôle dans
le sens où c'est vraiment bf ou excusez
moi on m'appelle j'étais salhab a
lâchement à faire mon cas mais case
méridien bardane alors on danse on se
voit ya des motos il ya des vastes
dévastant droit enfin ou [ __ ] on prend
cher c'est vraiment basse et battlefield
3 kw à l'état pur comparez un mapaq
comme avant qui était plutôt amère
dresse et ça fait combien de 6,4 comparé
au mapaq clos squatteurs va être de son
oncle aux quartz est on s'était les maps
plutôt vraiment serré il ya un tank
alors lui on se l'est fait promis et du
coup là ouais c c'est sympa moi j'aime
bien ça change un peu de dégoût des
matrix est justement de klaus carter
auquel on a pu jouer genre tourime bas
truc du genre
du coup l aie fait la même résumons
olala alors à la main ne olala on a une
moto mais alors mais radioactives mais
au petit lait tout fait péter long a boy
d'accord ça un français qu'avec moi il a
dit qu'on allait tout faire coter non
laissant des sens est né s'en remettre
mais en maintenant des 100 mecs avec tu
fais quoi
allô allô allô mec m heil en mai depuis
la moto ok c'est un mec comme ça
on y colle tant qu'il est là d'avenir
battue où c'était magnifique
c'est vraiment une technique de gros
troll croate de fac mais celle là on
peut quand même être un petit ralenti
parce que c'était mignon c'est très
mignon alors bon voila moi je m'éclate
un petit peu sur ce battlefield je suis
pas vraiment là voilà je joue un peu en
mode what the fuck bon pour moi c'est
quand même un jeu qu'il faut quand même
plutôt joué en équipe
j'avais pas de dire quand même anormal
mais ouais ça joue plutôt en équipe dans
le sens où des fois on tombe contre des
coéquipiers mais cette intelligence
après ce jeu des coéquipiers mais ils
ont le cul et d'une autruche en malaisie
c'est un truc de malade gens l'aimaient
qui sont des films et des fois mais
vraiment un bon après je pense pas que
c'est forcément bon vous me direz mais
nan mais il débute le jeu et tout mais
y'a pas y'a pas que des débutants qui
sont dans un rat sur et vous menace dans
le sens vraiment qu'ils sortent de je
sais pas faim oui c'est la gloire
ils sortent de je sais pas trop donc
c'est un peu un petit peu naze bon je
pense qu'on est tous tombés c'est comme
dans league of legend ou quoi on tombe
souvent regardés au nom au le trou du
cul fois l'erreur de merde de merde pas
moins aux mondieux j'y crois pas un
[ __ ] il m'a fauché la reculée l'avion
qu'il a fait dit stop et une barre le
mec genre calais logistics ami qui a
aimé son côté arnaud que le montant
qu'un pas bon bref
donc je disais oui parfois c'est comme
par exemple pour les joueurs de lol et
je sais qu'il y en a forcément entre
vous quand je tout seul fin justement on
a plutôt tendance à un jeu auquel on
joue avec ses avec vos amis ou quoi et
ça nous arrive même de rager contre nos
amis
et voilà c'est pas vraiment un jeu
auquel on prend du plaisir seul parce
qu'on peut vraiment vraiment tombé sur
des gens mauvais et dans battlefield 3
c'est un petit peu même si tu es bon tu
packtec que des gens mauvais loin de là
juste que quand il ya des gens mauvais
ça gâche un petit peu le plaisir du jeu
alors on est poursuivi par un hélico on
va aller là-bas ya toujours des
véhicules bas juste là bas la voyez lui
là bas on scrute et on se fait ch eck et
la tchèque et lattes madfrog
chad voyait on descendra moto elle fonce
maintenant au cera une technique
incroyable et en fait on s'est vraiment
pas mal d'élimination les jeunes
techniques comme ça ah oui il a fait
comment ils match aux snipers étaient
sur une moto bon mec tu fais du style
peur en étant sur ta moto tétreault part
c'est chelou ça bon alors on va on va on
voit cela refaire à ébène way la carte
air tranquille normale est de moto qui
se pointe assez souvent alors ce gun
totalement ridicule c'est le gars le
plus ridicule de la planète terre genre
avec eu un gros viseur une grosse
accueil de sinar mas
alors est ce qu'on pourra voir une moto
les autos motos on va me voilà oui donc
j'essaie tout ce que j'avais à dire par
rapport aux coéquipiers de bêtes mais
bon voilà après c'est un jeu pour moi on
se tape t un bâtard pour moi on se tape
des immenses barre sur ce jeu entre
potes même si vous voulez rien et on va
faire un petit truc si une moto apparaît
à mon avis en fait ils ont tous pris les
motos et les ont perdu là-bas et vu
qu'elles sont pas des quotas n'a pas
elle va parler de ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez énervant d'ailleurs alors
comment on va faire wahou away toi tu es
bien mort 1
waouh oui rebondi ouais moi car j'ai ma
mort je suis du coup je suis même plus
ce que je disais ouais alors on va faire
un petit truc de trois mois des pro la
moto pour le manteau annoncé le mec qui
fait avec moi le
tous ces cas ok c'est parti alors il va
sûrement pesé le seuil est en route à
mon avis on peut on peut se la jouer à
la première personne à l'est ainsi que
les offres innovantes
alors pour ceux qui savent pas font par
la troisième personne vous étiez sur ses
seins
on est sympa on affirme le connaissent
malheureusement là bas il ya deux temps
qu'on va s'en faire un des deux voies au
moment opportun je leur ai bien écraser
c'est un ennemi c'était pas aller mais
attendez attendez attendez là on va
faire les flux donc vraiment galets en
mode gros bâtards par le côté
alors là un temps qui s'est fait abattre
sur la droite vont y avait un ennemi bon
on s'en fout on va te coûter 1 300 tués
alors là je ris il nous a eu et nous a
vu ça va être chaud saatchi
oh non je suis dégoûté oh no oh non je
suis dégoûté non [ __ ] faut vraiment
content on est tous ah bon on va seul à
retenter tu marques un gros fuck alors
au pire ce qu'on peut faire
éventuellement mais bon même si ça avait
l'air un peu les gens qui prennent les
animaux pour faire ça
j'ai vu qu'on ne sait pas conduire on va
le faire c'est à dire que tu regardes et
oui la voiture juste là on va pas
l'appliquer à le ton que je donc le
temps regardez-moi sais rien moi ça
frotte à chute boom c4 au nom une
deuxième fois à à le faire non je suis
dégoûté [ __ ] ouais mais on dirait du
jus de tomate qu'on tire sur les gens
dans bf sas a eu sinon bon ta mère je me
suis carotte à 5 et une moto il ya une
moto moto tard bon cela refait on cela
refait on joue les kamikazes ni sur pet
alors allez c'est reparti [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] la haye mais en fait ce que
j'adorerais faire ce qui s'est vraiment
magnifique c e vous savez il ya une
bosse et où on descend la moto prend la
bosse un avion passe à côté de la moto
est là au fly choc
bon j'avoue j'ai cherché pendant que
fleischmann au tibet il ya plus
alors lui regarder le prix en est le
boom
quoi quoi les fans jack hayes au québec
même à la fac a au nom mais ils sont
sérieux jours
brad chavin qui pète ma moto au le mec
je peux focus des motos avec le ja rule
je savais même pas si jamie hince et les
véhicules terrestres d'accord oulala ça
fait longtemps moi je suis pas venu sur
ce battle fils de [ __ ] ça alors est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas un petit véhicule
peuvent peuvent pas j'arrive pas à voir
bon on va croiser les doigts
yes [ __ ] aller là faut qu'on arrête
pour effacer un truc girbaud vous savez
quoi va faire un petit clip de fou je
vais vous apprendre
on va aller sur la gauche et on va
contourner le champ de bataille
littéralement le balad félon ou tourner
mais vraiment vous allez voir on va se
retrouver alors oui ça va être chaud
parce qu'on va se faire flipper ya les
gens voient la jaf là les gens qui vont
vouloir notre peau notre peau de
kamikazes
alors est ce que j'aime wahou le doyen
sniper tout là bas où le voyez au loin
là-bas la somme à droite vers la bas il
avait un gros petit caf verse pas vous
savez quoi
c'est la guerre ici sales draps
c'est pas pour moi oui parfait
coucou non non et pourquoi je piquais
les epic fail dans la vidéo
je suis caché à ses cachets dernière
fois camara jamais pourquoi je fais que
des epic fail [ __ ] on a commencé en
beauté on finit en mauges total tu
dégoûté bon voila moi perso quand jouer
à battlefield 3 maintenant c'est
exactement ça que je fais alors certes
pour ce qui est des questions de ratio
mon ratio doit être équivalent à la le
taux de radioactivité
al'inverse du taux de radioactivité
comme une c4 ravi de ces quatre on va se
cacher derrière ça bouge pas je bouge
pas je nomme alors ce que j'adore faire
aussi en mode gros troll un bon ça c'est
vraiment une technique de bâtard et il
avance 0 avant 5 ou est-ce qu'il va
s'envoler au nom c'était trop pourri je
suis dégoûté merde n'entend non
mécanique matin il n'a pas attendu
il a volé la moto allait pense alors
pourquoi aller chez ce couple
on va essayer de les choper e banon va
choper objectifs du cas il m'avait le
plus proche
saout jobs continuait alors pas pop
on va aller sur
[ __ ] non y'a un truc capitaux à bas
tarifs entre la moto et ça m'a récemment
tu te dois bien me prévenir ouais ouais
on va apprendre à bâle alors qu'on a du
plain white t's pièce sur la fsi a pas
de troisième et par là je sais que là
bas et du coup il y avait juste là
- oh là là là là il s'est fait atomiser
on a combien de ces 4 4 j'ai vu un rayon
rouge dans ma face au mans je chie
dessus voilà match ok on va y retourner
et impose ses cadres posé sur la moto on
voit pas on verra jamais je crois qu'on
a vu au [ __ ] mais non bon autre façon
autant finir et la 68 à keith hackett
moi je veut s'attaquer au défi caisse
est inquiète non mais sérieusement les
gens je vais pas me faire la une comme
ça pendant 20 milliards d'années
attentats au nom merde
j'allais faire un attentat suicide à
l'avion et tout alors le gros défaut de
sa bien évidemment c'est que vigueur du
c4 sur votre moto le truc un petit peu
casse couilles c'est que tu es content
hier un petit peu sur vous pour être
juste un exclusif au rajout allez vas-y
jouent le jeu à genia beale 6 4 [ __ ]
mais lui non mais il utilise pour nous
propulser il est bête alors à prendre
toutes façons on a un peu aucun objectif
à pas apparaître l objectif d faggot y
aller c'est ok on est une des places
want to give a fuck toi là-bas on n'est
pas traité ma mère de bâtarde suit trois
ouvrages notre entrepôt vieux des choses
comme ça où tout proche allez les gars
on trop d'impôts j'aimerais jamais mais
c'est au n est pas mal ça plus tard oui
en espèces de 20 10 ans avec une arme
est tout ouïe can caste
grâce à l'avion turc arda l'avion or
jallet alors là vous allez voir
on va faire un pic est là et les angels
il va être magnifique
allez vite avant que ça finisse on
applique 27 ticket on va essayer de
péter cet avion qui s'est pété lui même
à temps d'attendre on sait qu'on va
faire un kamikaze à bas les couilles à
quoique non d'azur le prochain on prend
en chasse à wii fit wii qu'existe une
chasse boum boum à lévis et de reculer
c'est trop tendue j'abandonne soldats je
retourne chez ma mère
vas-y focus que non mais son sérieux
olala les battles désert c'est tellement
dur les gens aulas alors d'ailleurs d'en
bas depuis trois petits défauts que je
trouve c'est que bon bah tartas encore
telle heure
morales finir la mitraillette ci
continue donc
boum la tap à telle heure aux abonnés
bon allez hop merde l'heure
punaise couvert très fier et on est en
position temporise on temporise comme le
genre de call of duty qui temporise on
temporise bien là c'est du temps pour
âge de luxe si tu veux du bon temps
poteau pour tom temporise âge waouh
c'est qu'après par michael jackson
attendent attendent et espèrent qu
est-ce que là on est vraiment dans la
merde jusqu'au pied jusqu'au cou pardon
va si bien là bien là intervient là il
se prit officie lille dauphin
c'était magnifique [ __ ] mais merde
mais whaou aux mecs sniper campeurs
mcguigan au il est sérieux envers de le
et on est bien dans notre bâtiment on
épouse est apte à vue et manquerait plus
qu'un petit fake à café chocolat chaud
la [ __ ] enfin libre à vous c'est quoi
un côté nazis alors là les gens si je
voulais rentrer on n'aura pas le temps
on n'en a pas tant vas-y foncé mon avion
france font font font font font font
font salles fonce alphonse j'ai vu un
mec juste là on va faire celui là au
shit mais où
oui on va jeter ses chaussures au [ __ ]
les gens cette vidéo battlefield en mode
en mode on fait des vagues en mode
kamikazes ont fait un mois que c'était
vraiment hallucinant on a fini par faire
du cep 13 c'est pas grave on a plein de
casser le cul aux gens moi je vous dis
pis si vous voulez plus de battlefield 3
ne sait pas laquelle ils doivent poster
un commentaire la mettre en favoris à
dire je t'aime cluzet et puis on
scrutera g gallas est ce que je suis
passé une bonne partie une bonne vidéo
je suis content on se retrouve bientôt
nouvelle vidéo chat le monde peas et à
bientôt